une autre journée chaotique dans la
capitale haïtienne et un autre citoyen
qui vient de perdre la vie cela fait une
semaine que le sang coule à port au
prince avec en moyenne un mort par jour
les affrontements entre les
protestataires et les forces de l'ordre
ne faiblissent pas c'est à coups de tirs
et de grenades lacrymogènes que la
police tente depuis jeudi dernier de
contenir le mouvement de contestation
au milieu de ces confrontations
violentes ce sont les scènes de pillages
qui se multiplient contre les commerces
de la ville
il est policier sont plutôt dépourvu
quand vient le temps d'arrêter les
malfaiteurs dans cette atmosphère
d'anarchie même la télévision nationale
haïtienne a été la cible d'un incendie
des arrestations des blessés qui
s'entassent dans des véhicules et des
haïtiens qui font la file dans l'espoir
d'obtenir de l'essence la situation ne
semble pas près de se calmer gens là
doivent ouanna jouvenel est un voleur
dit ce manifestant
tant qu'il ne partira pas nous resterons
dans les rues je venais le moïse élu
président d'haïti qu'il y a deux ans a
réitéré vendredi dernier que la
population avait voté pour lui
nous pouvons à l'arrêt tout frêne tout
jeune sa porte est toujours ouverte dit
il pour parler des difficultés
auxquelles son pays fait face rien pour
convaincre les manifestants
c'est de politicien lui et son premier
ministre sont des criminels du celui ci
il devrait être en prison
il faut dire que dans un rapport de la
cour des comptes qui a révélé un
scandale de corruption apparaît le nom
de joël moïse mais aussi ceux d'une
quinzaine d'anciens ministres
au coeur de cette affaire des
détournements de fonds des do
développement fournies par le venezuela
un scandale dont joël moïse n'avait pas
besoin
lui qui se faisait déjà montré la porte
en novembre dernier par une population
frappée par une pauvreté endémique
le président haïtien disent ses
opposants n'a toujours pas respecté sa
promesse de lutter contre la vie chère
car les mauvaises nouvelles continuent
de s'accumuler pour la population le
taux d'inflation est à 15% et la monnaie
nationale
la gourde a été dévalué face au dollar
américain
résultat comme haïti importe une
majorité de produits
tout est hors de portée pour les
citoyens bref la colère arrivent de
partout pour manifester et tout ce qu'on
veut tout ça converge contre le
président gbagbo qui est à re mandat de
cinq ans
[Applaudissements]
en attendant haïti continue de
s'enflammer ici frédéric arnould radio
canada montréal